but ice you took part in a panel
discussion today about do we really need
fiber now before you tell me your answer
tell me about your organization and then
the main points that you were making to
that panel okay I am the chairman of
cable Europe which is basically the
European Organization of all cable
operators like UPC like kabel
deutschland like virgin so we are
assembling the interests of the cable
industry in Europe and coming back to
your question do we really need fiber I
think fiber is everywhere you know even
get cable networks have a lot of fiber
in their backbones and fiber obviously
will go very closer to the house
incremental e because the development of
the download of broadband traffic will
need that you know but the cable
industry does it incrementally and we
only discuss it's a very very last mile
and in the very last mile though it was
a copper network which cable has is like
a kind of a gold mine because our
technicians our engineers invented a
standard called boxes I don't go to the
details who is able now and I just got
some news about it to develop gigabyte
symmetrical both ways over this last
mile in cable so I think if there is a
cable network and that's in fifty
percent of the European household we
take it to answer to that because we
could immediately offer people already
now 500 mega bits with the old standard
with a new standard we could offer them
gigabits so we think this system this
hybrid system will be fit for a long
time fit for purpose and the advantages
you can incrementally in West you don't
need this big money of investment at a
time to go take up the fiber network to
the house you know and the customer
doesn't notice he has the same kind of
quality is the same kind of experience
and service oh that's the only thing we
discussing and if there would be no
cable network I think even cable
operators would sink in a green field to
invest directly in fiber to the home
maybe maybe but it's up to the operators
to do that but it would be a big mistake
to underestimate the value for the
existing cable infrastructure in the
last mile
while all this is going on what's your
view on the regulatory situation at the
moment it hasn't been that bad because
it's encouraged especially
infrastructure based competition and
cable our members are one of the main
driving force for high quality broadband
in Europe and our members benefit from
this infrastructure competition and in
areas where you have one hundred percent
cable coverage we have the best service
all over Europe so I sink infrastructure
competition is one key for get a quality
get better quality in broadband and when
competition works we could face out of
regulation this is already embedded in
the existing regulatory framework that
could be a little bit enhanced for
next-generation networks but you look
market by market but I think there is no
longer justification for regulation if
this infrastructure competition has so
fantastic results for the consumer yes
now you finish with the magic word the
consumer there sometimes we forget about
the consumer what do you think matters
most to them at the moment I think
consumers want to have a seamless
experience and they want to have a whole
bundle of different services at a very
reasonable price and that what cable
operators can offer you know we have
embedded Wi-Fi systems we have embedded
even content even high quality content
in a triple play bundle you know so it's
important not to sing only about
infrastructure it's important to think
about the services and what we see right
now is we are running ahead of the
demand you know so we would like the
politicians and the regulator and EU
commission to look more on the side of
the demand what can we do to stimulate
more the demand of new services and
that's a holistic view I think for a
digital Europe and we will deliver I'm
sure we will deliver the best
infrastructure broadband solution which
is technically feasible it's been
talking about the EU what what do you
think is the one single thing they could
do to help should have deliver on this
digital single market besides the demand
stimulation and besides thinking about
it I think the regulation which they do
should enable investment I think that's
a key issue because public money public
funding never can do the job
you know most of the money is coming
from private companies and from private
investors and they are very sensible on
changes in the regulatory framework so
what we should do is to look on these
private investors who by the way have
deliver the great job in the past it's
not that they have done nothing you know
they have delivered very good quality
and listen a little bit more what these
investors want and then in the end of
the day investors listen also on the
demand of the customers you know so if
you want to have a good business in a
competitive environment there is no way
that you have to listen to your customer
and to support the needs of the custom
so this is a healthy environment and I
think we should learn out of this
healthy environment and not distorting
it that's the main my main message to
the Commission sometimes thank you very
much for talking to us Thank You Brad